bienvenue dans ces fameuses nouvelles
vidéos dans lesquelles j'expérimente des
activités manuelles qui sont mon gros
point faible mais j'ai envie de
m'améliorer
oui j'ai appréhendé une fois de plus
avant de tourner cette vidéo la cale
rond dans la case de celle ci mais comme
les deux premières ça va très bien se
passer j'en suis convaincu vous
connaissez tous ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui je pense que vous en avez
tous au moins essayer un dans votre vie
pour la simple et bonne raison que pour
en faire il faut juste une feuille de
papier et qu'on a normalement tout ça
chez nos ligues à mi mot qui nous vient
tout droit du japonais qu'il aurait lui
même emprunté aux chinois oui je suis en
train de lire la définition sur google
est alors alors comme pour le dessin et
les casse tête j'ai un passif avec les
origamis un peu moins gros je n'ai qu'un
peu moins gros tant mieux c'est un peu
plus léger l'histoire autour quand
j'étais petit avec mon père on faisait
pas mal de riga me et souvent ils
acheter du papier spécial carrément pour
faire des avions acheté une sorte de bac
il y avait des feuilles cartonnées
dedans tu découpes et ça te faisais des
formes tu les emboîter et avait un avion
mais de ouf mec pas du tout l'avion
péter vous avez tous lancés en ce2 a
trait à la classe et en dehors de ces
packs là pour faire des avions et dans
des fois on essaie de faire des trucs un
peu plus classique avec du papier
parfaitement normal on essayait de faire
je me souviens de mémoire une grenouille
et un bateau est ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose ou pas eh bien écoutez
aujourd'hui regardez j'ai moi même
acheter du papier de couleur qui est
fait pour faire de l'origami je sait pas
du tout quelle est la différence papier
là et des feuilles à cannes normal
aujourd'hui nous allons quinze ans plus
tard peut-être même 16 ans plus tard
reproduire ces deux trucs là que je
faisais à l'époque avec mon père mais
sans mon père donc c'est le plus
complexe on va suivre ça bien évidemment
des tutoz sur internet qui sont très
cool et en 3e origami une petite
surprise un truc j'ai vu j'ai fait ou
wat mais si je veux le faire
ok commençons avec le petit bateau c'est
parti le tuto dure 4 minutes genre c'est
le plus simple prenez tout ce à quoi
prenez tous une feuille de papier en
vrai faisait toutefois si vous mettez en
pause ramener une feuille a4 et enfin
ensemble bâton les cassettes vous pouvez
pas forcément parce qu'il fallait le
casse tête chez lui et vous l'aviez pas
acheter mais là il faut juste une fois
que vous avez pas d excuses allez on s'y
colle on fait un truc manuel tous
ensemble ok il a fait un beau bateau il
a fait une belle barque et finitions
sont belles les finitions sont calibrés
le travail a été effectué avec soins
auxquels ces particules de tuto donc je
crois que c'est le petit papier bleu on
y va c'est parti je stresse or tout
d'abord on replie la feuille sur
elle-même j'adore comme ça commence tout
le temps simple et comme tu as envie de
critiquer alors que ça va très vite
partir en couille attend ça fait de la
torre j'ai participé ça ça fait vraiment
de smr le bruit des mains sur le papier
[Musique]
encore une fois les amis je suis le pire
mais qu'entre manuel je suis une merde
mais c'est scandaleux et du coup ces
vidéos là me forcer face des activités
manuelles parce que je veux faire des
activités manuelles au quotidien mais je
trouve sur des excuses j'ai pas le temps
j'ai sujet ça a lâché obligé pour le
bien de la vidéo chat obligé et ça ça
motive alors je le fais ah voilà c'est
ça les pièges c'est que des fois il faut
près il faut plier mais réouvrir et plus
tard on comprendra pourquoi on a fait ce
qu'il a fait pour le moment on ne peut
pas comprendre à ça on connaît c'est la
forme de l'avion au papier vous l'avez
tout cela on l'a tous ne mentait pas à
du coup est ce que le plus d'avant
servait à se faire une ligne droite pour
savoir comment je me suis perdu dans
cette explication vous pouvez le
remarquer
[Musique]
mais là ça me démange là ça me démange
totalement on a envie de faire koala un
avion regard des jours où il ya juste à
faire ça à plier comme ça à relever les
allées on a un avion bateau lui qu'un
bateau arrête d'être un enfant qui rêve
de lancer l'avion plus loin que les
copains arrête
[Musique]
oh merde non non regardez il ya une
imperfection de ce côté là tant pis
c'est pas grave je on l'a déjà dit dans
une vidéo ses les imperfections qui font
qu'on aime
j'ai oublié la morale de cette vidéo
d'ailleurs allé au livre bon ça s'ouvre
roche il est pas parfaite du tout la de
ce côté là je sais pas pourquoi
oh non mais non mais pourquoi pourquoi
ça fait ça mais j'ai tout fait comme lui
ça ça m'énerve quoi je fais tout comme
lui moyens truc qui bug
rien n'est parfait rien du tout ça me
donne chaud c'est que le début qu'elle
vient de remettre en question j'ai
compris un truc que je suis pas qu il
fait c'est ça la vie j'ai bien fait le
plein hier je suis un rageux oui ok
ensuite il faudra battre cette partie là
sur celle du haut c'est ok
puisque j'ai réussi à temps après il est
moins bon que le siège suis d'accord
avec vous mais je crois qu'il y renonce
à regarder regardez ça comme ça témoigne
de ma faiblesse et je vois pas qui le
mandat une barque moment j'ai un petit
carré qui a du mal un clairement là on
voit qu'il s'est cognée pris le connais
le petit doigt de pied de la table du
salon on connaît tous
wahou
nancy lui galère mais qu au [ __ ] cette
étape
ok
[Musique]
les amis je crois que c'est bon c'est
bon on coache bourg le bateau est fait
écoutez moi bien c'est exactement ce
bateau là je faisais quand j'étais petit
c'est exactement cela vous le connaissez
vous aussi vous voulez un test en
conditions réelles je comprends je
comprends nous allons faire ça avec la
gamelle de nation attention les amis ce
moment de vérité aurais-je pu avoir un
travail manuel
aurais-je pu exceller et finir par et à
mon compte et devenir riche attention
oui bon il est vrai que si je suis
honnête à tout moment il peut couler
vraiment j'avoue là vraiment un côté qui
penche très fort vers l'eau par rapport
à l'autre il ya vraiment un gros
problème tant d est ce qu'on peut mettre
quelque chose dedans le poids d'une
bague l'a vraiment là les rangs dont sa
gamelle à natsu et passons à la
grenouille the days où on va la faire
jaune
j'adore le jeu ok ce parti ai'a pas les
petits schémas haut à droite là bas
alors on préférait l'autre chaîne
youtube qu'est ce que c'est que ça y est
tu veux voler la place au numéro 1 de
l'origami sur youtube c'est ça et tu
fais même pas les petits schémas
jusque là tout est clair en pliant de la
feuille a opiné le montrent avec ses
doigts à temps c'est pas mal en fait
[Musique]
ok un angle on remonte en haut c'est
d'accord je m'applique à cheveux que
mike godwin briegel hostile voilà à
n'ont pas encore ça j'ai le syndrome de
l'avion j'ai envie de faire la même là
je crains ridicule à temps mais on plie
pour eux pour nous pour ne rien faire là
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça là je
puis on n'en fait rien ça me frustre qui
ont fait la même de l'autre côté un de
manière symétrique évidemment ok c'est
fait et maintenant
[Musique]
well obel là quand même
voilà la tendance est bien sûr la ola là
je suis perdu j'ai réussi pour moi ou ça
me fait comme pour le dessin je ressens
à nouveau ses sensations je suis heureux
attendez attendez puisque je suis en
train de prendre l'appel concerne
origami est ce que le move d'après c'est
pas de faire la même chose mais de
l'autre côté
oui oui
non mais moi je vous dis je vais
ouvriers troisième chaîne youtube
cuisery gamme hausse
on y va pour le moment je sais pas où
est la grenouille pour le moment je vous
le dis la vérité je n'ai aucune idée
d'où et la grenouille
c'est un mec ça devient mais gac
compliqué oh c'est dégueulasse par
rapport à elle c'est la honte faut que
j'arrête ces vidéos là je crois que
c'est celle de trop ouais d'accord c'est
carrément celle de trop nathan mais j'ai
fait grave de la merde
non mais j'ai fait trop de la merde là
regardez comme c'est pas droit du tout
là c'est fou ça de s'apercevoir au d'un
moment que ça fait de la merde tient
dessin tu le sens arriver tu a relaté
hyper confiant jusqu'au bout et en fait
tu as fait de la merde et attends moi je
rêve on dirait le un avion d'un plan
papier la minute suis l'un est d'accord
qu'il ya un avion en papier là on est
d'accord
à l'ehpad du mois la suite s'il te plaît
j'ai juste envie de faire sauter cette
[ __ ] de l'europe du moins pas qu'il
faut repayer un truc sur lui-même parce
que j'aurais pas la force je n'ai pas la
force
c'est exactement s'il faut faire je m et
c'est fou à quel moment tout est parti
en couille
on était bien je vous jure viège
comprends pas je ne comprends pas cette
personne fait avec ce bout de papier
j'ai envie de dire de le laisser
tranquille déjà de pourquoi tu la grèce
ce papier laisse le vase et je me suis
lancé je me suis lancée sur le pli de
l'inconnu e
j'ai raté ou pas non ça a l'air bon ça
al'air brouel monte comme ça la courbe
je crois que je suis bien c'est tout
est-ce qu'on est d'accord pour dire
qu'il manque quelque chose de crucial
dans ce tutoriel vous laisse deux
secondes pour réfléchir et voilà nous
avons enfin vladimir la grenouille avec
nous parce que vous êtes prêt à voir en
direct live le premier saut de la vie de
vladimir la grenouille mec c'est un
sketch
pourquoi je rate tout ce que
j'entreprends dans les gammes et [ __ ]
de merde là je termine moi pourquoi je
n'ai pas remis à sa place [ __ ] bon
écoutez quand je vous dis que là c'était
l'échauffement c'est que c'était
vraiment l'échauffement le vrai
challenge de cette vidéo c'est ce qui va
suivre mes amis suis là quand je les ai
vus je me suis dit [ __ ] de merde j'ai
même pas que c'était possible
mot pour mot je me suis dit ça dans ma
tête regardez s'il vous plaît ceci c'est
un origami à d'araignée il est
incroyable il est dingue il faut deux
papiers et on va devoir les assemblées
c'est pas aux fennecs
allez on va le faire en rouge parce que
j'ai pas de noir une araignée rouge
finalement on lui phrase pour lui fera
des points noirs
elle est depuis pourtant c'est parti
premières feuilles j'adore le premier
pli le premier prix il est d'une
simplicité au il me fait du bien ce pli
la la ohlala sais quoi je réponds tout
mon temps
ces objets de sifflets quand je fais un
pli sastre satisfaisant aux le deuxième
bail ont fait la même chose dans l'autre
sens elle finira pas dans l'eau et je
vous préviens on va pas faire trois fois
la même erreur
hoballah non mais attendez s et un tuto
pour les ce2 ou quoi je sais qu'au fond
de vous vous trouvez ça un peu ridicule
ce que je fais mais vous avez un peu
envie d'essayer
je vois très bien dans vos yeux ce qui
se passe si vous avez un plan et vous
vous dites franchement c'est nul c'est
un gars j'aimerais bien voir un petit
arrêt niant pas pierrot attend quoi qu
attends attends attends qu est ce qu il
a fait il fait mal au crâne au [ __ ]
j'ai plus de plaisir j'ai déjà plus de
plaisir ok faut mettre ses gros doigts
dans le trou l'un pour écarter et rabat
à mes mecs c'est la folie là je peux
ainsi un petit bateau envoyé de danger
avec salah n'a pas dit ça le coup de
ciseaux un bâtard c'est beaucoup plus
pratique mon pote nommé mec c'est
incroyable comme c'est chaud puisqu'ils
veulent même pas c'est incroyable de
complexité l'aca étonnamment je pense
que si vous emballez trop bien les
cadeaux genre vous allez trop pas
galérer à faire les origamis c'est un
peu le même délire ça vous fait pas
penser ça ça là j'ai un truc là c'est le
bout du cadeau et une fois et ça reste
large comme ça quand tu mets scotch est
ce qu'un a consacré ça me fait très
plaisir
la deuxième faille c'est la rive oui
[Musique]
c'est la pire chose qui pouvait arriver
donc ça dure pas 14 minutes 46 tuto ça
dure 30 minutes au moi [ __ ] à 20
h allez on y va rester là ah bah ça
marche nickel son truc à elle c'est lent
c'est faux j'ai galéré 35 minutes c'est
bon allez on y va
[Musique]
bon il maintenant temps de fusionner ces
deux [ __ ] de pièces et là je me chie
dessus parce que là je vais vous dire je
me suis tellement donné là dessus j'ai
nullement envie de me rater sur ce qui
suit nullement vous comprenez tac
colette oi oi oi oi oi oi laissera pas
des mais ça ne marche pas du tout ça ne
marche pas du tout je veux dire la
vérité ce qui est grave dur c'est de ne
pas perdre de vue ce qu'il fait parce
que sinon tu es mort genre là j'ai rien
compris au caire des petits plis sachant
qu'il nous ramène rien puisque derrière
pour faire tout ça avec le deuxième
oui vas-y mais d'où il nous ya pas de
souci les amis je suis en train
d'angoissé j'ai peur que après avoir
fait tout ça il y a une révélation une
sorte de révélation bizarroïde i et ben
voilà vous avez fait deux pattes et fois
offert 8
ok maintenant [ __ ] on fait les pattes
là bas je pensais pas un jour que je
serais heureux de voir des pattes
d'araignée
jamais de ma vie
[Musique]
bon j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai pu on
obtient un cul d'araignée assez
satisfaisant là j'avoue j'ai fait des
trolls c'est comme si le dessin j'avais
j'avais tenté un portrait robot je me
suis peut-être un peu surestimé à tintin
tintin tintin attentats temps est ce
qu'il vient de dire ce qu'il faut faire
en sous titre au lieu de le faire sous
la caméra il a dit faites ça criait
on est jeudi au moment je tourne je vais
dans la vie dans une heure devant alors
d'alors ike et souple à anna haag autres
lots à faut souffler dedans vous devez
souffler dans le hockey c'est bon ça
c'est le moment de vérité
oh oui monsieur pouvait lui souffler
dedans toute la journée dans ces [ __ ]
d'araignée ok ok qu'est ce qu'on fait
que le papier steuplé maintenant qu'on a
le corps je vais la tête les pattes et
est rentré chez moi pour faire mon live
et est non [ __ ] encore ça j'en ai ma
[ __ ] c'est horrible c'est le truc que
schwarz alors je perd patience vous et
c'est pour ça que je suis nul en tout
manuel c'est que j'ai pas de patience et
c'est horrible c'est mort je n'arrive
pas en fait je n'arrive pas à voir la
même chose que lui ici donc j'ai dû me
tromper yahyavi à 33 minutes et c'est
que je me rends compte qu'il ya tourner
trois minutes j'ai fait de la merde et
je peux rien faire pour rattraper cette
merde c'est quoi j'en ai marre de suivre
les règles
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui vais créer mes
propres règles qui vais inventer ma
propre histoire et pas suivi la sienne
vous allez voir moi ce que je vais faire
vous allez voir
[Musique]
messieurs dames après 34 minutes de
conception ingénierie de qualité laissez
moi vous présenter le si beau tu voulais
je fasse une araignée et pas j'ai fait
une fourmi vont lui si t'en fais pas je
te présente vladimir ton petit frère est
ici c'est le cadavre de toto le bateau
des amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'ai fait des dégâts miba vous voyez
pour une fois j'avais j'avais raison
d'appréhender le tournage je me suis
complètement foiré en vrai je suis quand
même très satisfait parce que j'ai quand
même réussi à faire un truc qui
ressemble à une fourmi rouge
je suis très sérieux quand je dis ça ne
me brisez pas le coeur en me disant que
c'est mon imagination ils sont retirés
les yeux ça ressemble à rien j'espère
tout de même bien vidéo vous aura plu je
pense que montage aurait été périlleux
merci bravo clément d'avoir monté cette
vidéo je sais pas comment tu as fait
mais bravo je me suis tout de même
éclaté j'ai quand même refait le petit
bateau que je faisais quand j'étais
petit est la grenouille quand vous avec
des tickets de métro a que mon père donc
je suis un peu touché quand même ça me
fait quelque chose n'hésitez pas en tout
cas chez vous à faire des trucs un peu
manuel un peu ludique un peu drôle comme
ça j'ai vu qu'à plein de gens qui sont
bien faire des casse tête
après la vidéo que j'ai fait comme ça
sur les casse-têtes m'avait envoyé plein
de photos de vidéos il y en a même qui
sont mis à faire des soirées casse tête
entre potes et où je trouve ça génial je
trouve ça cool moi j'avoue j'ai très peu
fait ça dans ma ville et rapho je le
fais c'est en vidéo avec vous et je
trouve cette roucoule gens me le fais
avec des potes maintenant je vous dis à
bientôt merci avoir regardé n'hésitez
pas si vous avez d'autres idées
d'activités un peu manuel moi j'en ai
quelques unes mais on sait jamais
peut-être vous en avez aussi et qui est
auquel j'ai pas pensé donc n'hésitez pas
à venir d'un commentaire et puis je lui
dis a perdu une prochaine vidéo passé
toujours de très bonnes vacances on se
trouve dans une prochaine vidéo très
bientôt
gros bisous et merci lui si je la mets
là je la touche plus jamais regardé bien
[Musique]
allez merci à tous sportifs ou bien je
suis fumée j'ai besoin de sortir de deux
heures de techno
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]